brewdog has built a global business on a
heady mix of beer and branding
the self-declared punks made kraft ale
cool
but now stand accused of allowing a
toxic atmosphere to ferment
more than 300 former employees have
signed an open letter accusing the
company's founders of an aggressive
culture
that excuse sexism and misogyny the true
culture of brewdog they write
is and seemingly always has been fear
it was really good and it was a really
enjoyable place to work
until it wasn't and when it wasn't
it was horrific maria not her real name
worked for brewdog for three years i was
on 19 and doing
60 hour weeks and being berated by the
boss
you know there was there was no such
thing as a small
you know a small forgivable mistake it's
a cult of personality
the personality in question is james
watt the co-founder now promising an
independent review of the business he
built after stinging personal criticism
much of it from women we've always had a
high performance culture i've always
been
perhaps too demanding as a people
manager i'm very focused
on what we're doing i'm very passionate
about what we're doing and sometimes
that passion can come across there's too
much intensity
when it comes to managing people do you
consider yourself a misogynist
um never for a single second if i
consider that and we have got over 2
000 people in the company we've got so
many fantastic team members here with
brilliant stories to tell of how they've
built their career
obviously in this instance we've let
some individuals down on their journey
with us we apologize for that
we're good to look to address that but i
don't think it takes the full picture of
our culture our company
brewdog has gone from edgy outsider to
established brand leader in just
14 years it's got more than 1600
employees here
at its aberdeen headquarters and more
than 100 bars
in the uk alone but some former staff
say this
remarkable growth has come at too high a
price
it's a challenge for the wider industry
too according to writer siobhan buchanan
who has collected and shared more than
200 testimonies
from workers at dozens of brewers i
think this is definitely a me too moment
for the craft brewing industry there's
been stories from
tiny breweries up to nationwide
big names and it's it's it's pervasive
it's an issue of systemic toxicity with
regards to women long-term brewdog plans
a stock market listing that could net
its founders a fortune investors may
wonder whether the punk ethos that got
them
here can survive the scrutiny that comes
with a grown-up business
paul kelso's sky news in aberdeen